that's why i was like yeah i didn't say
you almost didn't dirty they did me die
like i was speaking and then they just
was mad
you had them you mean that's life hey i
just wanted to say thank you first of
all
uh for for using your your acceptance
speech and your spotlight
to shine the fact on the fact that fred
hampton's life and what and what he
lived was more important than just the
stories of
of him passing um and i just really
wanted to thank you for that
you also referenced nipsey hustle you
said you gave until you were empty you
also said fred hampton
made you a better person so what do you
think what do you
thank fred hampton for the most frank
hunter i thank him for his love man
and his compassion and the amount of
self-love he had and how much he poured
into the black community
you know and like and and didn't
compromise on that
you know and he he's he's he's a
brilliant brilliant brilliant man i've
never
encountered anyone like him then so it's
um
that sometimes i really speeches just
randomly and saying that's how d
that's how much he gave and um i thank
you i thank him
for for his life
okay next question comes from hollywood
unlocked alexis joy
hello how are you congratulations
first award of the night um now
fred hampton's story was a very a very
important story that needed to be seen
on the big screen and of course it was
released
during black history month you won this
award during black history month
what does this this moment mean to you
this this what you talking about the
moment tonight or the moment in general
in general to be able to tell fred
hampton's story and to be able to be
awarded for it
to tell the story is justin is man
that's a privilege you know what i'm
saying it's an honor
i feel mad humble in this current moment
to be real
and like i feel like if i was four years
older i can't play this role you know
so it's just it's like uh i feel really
aligned so
i just feel grateful you know saying and
i feel grateful for the award to allow
more people to watch you know this film
that um
everyone come together came together and
made you know and to continue the legacy
of chairman fred
thank you next question
from essence brand victorian
hello how are you
but how are you good thank you uh
congratulations
on your win tonight um similar to a
question before
with quoting nipsey hustle and talking
about giving it your everything
can you talk about what it took uh for
you to play chairman hampton and what
lesson from his life you'll take with
you as you go forward in your
life and career
um say that again sorry see you again uh
what what did it take for you to step
into his shoes chairman fairhampton and
what lesson from his life will you take
with you as you go forward in your life
and your career
uh it took everything everything and
more
like i found more um i had to find more
um and the lesson is just
it's clarity no clarity of full crowd
you're feeling
clarity of giving you know um and
and just self love and how much
how much they love their own i'll keep
that with me forever
thank you next question comes from ap
damian pugh
hello congratulations sir this is denia
pugh
i've met you before what's happening you
you have we talked not too long ago and
i want to kind of go back to our
conversation because
i remember you mentioning how a
different you showed up in order to
portray uh chairman fred hampton so i'm
wondering now
with the film being considered one of
the best recognized as one of the best
in all of your hard work
talk to me about how full circle this
moment is for you if that's the case
daniel
uh yeah i mean
we did it you know we made it saying
it's so hard for films like this to be
made
and that's the win for me that's the
that's the win i like with the fact that
we
told it from this perspective you have
to give your hat um
what's that tip your hat to ryan coogler
when he made a billy and he pitched this
you know like it's certain so many
things have to happen
in order for this film to get made like
fresh white could try to make it and
until antoine falcon tried to make it
it's a lot of people tried to make this
film so
the fact that we were able to make it is
the biggest win and the fact that
uh a mainstream audience is arriving to
it and arriving to this story is
everything
you're up guys
[Laughter]
it's different it's different daniel
congratulations
uh first first time winning your golden
globes for fred
playing chairman fred hampton i mean how
important
and and relevant is this award for you
winning this at a time right now
playing chairman fred hampton um what
what do you want that message
to be for us today
is to know the people that are on the
front line are really doing changes
really doing the battles
people that are responding to to the
murders of george floyd and brianna
taylor
that they work they're not alone they
can look in history and there's a line
of people who really fought and really
believed in what they believed in and
they had the words and they had
distracted
nothing to implement it and it's like
they're not crazy
and she's gone oh let's laugh hey daniel
what's up
hello how are you i'm good i'm good good
to see you again
great to see you too so listen we've
congratulations on the wind obviously
we've heard you you shouted out nipsey
hustle the brilliant nipsy hustle could
you see yourself
bring helping to bring his story to life
uh we know you can brilliantly bring
other people's story to life would you
be
interested in helping to bring his story
to life
i want to see it like i don't know i
definitely don't think i should play
nipsey hustle during
considering my complexion but um but uh
i feel like uh i wanna
hopefully want to see it just saying and
if i can help then i can help but
i just want it to exist i mean that's
like everything i just want things to
exist
and sometimes i'm the word person that's
the the vessel and the kind of person
that's gonna but
i'm just happy certain things exist you
know um that's all i'm
you know that's all i'm in the business
of
you